foreign
[Music]
space acts of objects and want to
understand what is the largest
a chapter of x that satisfies the
restrictions we have some institutional
subsets and want to understand what is
the external set the largest satisfies
Data Solutions
for example as we mentioned we have this
notion of an intersection family
Okay so
family
f is intersecting
the intersection of each Concepts in the
family is not empty
okay so this is the example for k equal
to 2. when we have
um this is not intersecting because it
has two disjoint edges and here we have
the trivial intersecting family the
dictator of all edges that contain a
given vertex here
we have an intersecting family that's
not contaminated
and there
business and an ocean and a double Squad
theorem that we mentioned earlier says
that the external intersecting families
are the dictators
and this is basically the philosophy of
the Elder theorem that if you want to
and sometimes when you have external
problems the trivial solution is
actually the largest one and
and
this elder scroll
it started a subfield of external
combinatorics of a whole variety of
external problems where the external
solutions from conjecture to be
dictators
so
and let's
say a little bit more about it
starts
they
found this notion of this class of
external problems called two and
problems for expansion
and
uh
these these included and
this included some open problems from
the 70s
and where the external solution was
conjectured to be dictate
the external solution
was conjectured either to be a dictator
actually or
food
indicator
and okay let's give like a sample
problem so there is this 1975
will be an intersection problem
s
and any tasks how large
family of set being
if the intersection of each two sets in
F
is not of a given size
these problem is relations to coding
Theory and
and
this is one sample problem or the
external solution with conjecture to be
a hunter you can take the family
of all sets
and that contain one application
okay so t plus one in that trench let's
let's call it T minus one just to make
it nicer okay and so this is One
external solution and there is also
another for 700 of the parameters there
is another external solution and
we can take instead of the family of all
sets that was intersection with one up
to t plus two r
but this is at least t plus r
is another a
another example of a family
it satisfies this condition that the
intersection of each two sets in the
family is not of size T minus one
and
yes and
yeah now the screen predict doesn't work
okay
[Music]
yes service family of all a
that's the intersection of a with
oops
it's two hours at least two plus hour
that's an example of a tintersecting uh
intersecting family so the section which
two sets in the family is not a size T
minus one and actually in the section of
each two sets in the family decides at
least
okay
and these problems were studied first
for families of sets but they were also
studied in algebraic combinatorics where
they'll studied over groups and each
time when we try to solve this problem
for a different group you it involves
the representation theory of this group
and
and it motivates and
lots of nice representation Theory and
then
okay
we'll not talk about today
so okay so we have the established so
Boolean functions can also be sort of as
like voting schemes when we have to
choose between two options we have a
let's say pizza or ice cream
and then we have the dictatorship
function well we choose what one person
decides and we also have the Junta
example well we only three people
determine what we eat this is
and it turns out that
this Punta method it's uh so
is some method that helps solve these
other Squad type problem so
it's not only a message that's helpful
in Boolean functions and in Social
Choice it's also helpful in external
combinatorics and
and
indeed what we managed to show
[Music]
foreign
yeah so
Okay so
what we could
so Alice Keller and and me
would that
Yeah so basically solved
the elbow interception problem
foreign
most
and half minus Epsilon times and when K
is larger than half this part this
problem doesn't make any sense and
it's sufficiently large with respect to
Epsilon and T
and the main notion that we used was
this notion of fundas so what are
hunters from families of sex
and family if you want to understand
whether a set belongs to the family if
you can throw away all the elements of a
to the garbage instead of the Junta
coordinates and just look at a
intersection of a with j and based on
that decide whether a belongs to the
family or not
for example
we can take
the set of all a in F
such that one is an a
this is a dictator
and we can also take the set of a and as
that
the intersection of a
the set one two three
at least two
this is the example of a
Junta and this is a an intersecting this
family is an intersecting family the
intersection of each two sets in s is
non-empting
foreign
they show that
every intersecting family is essentially
contained in an intersection so that's
the structure of all the intersecting
families if I want to construct an
intersecting family I can start with an
intersecting junta
and then I can always remove elements
from the intersecting Junta and it will
still be intersecting and then I can
only add few elements outside of the
Honda
and that's basically the structure of
all the intersecting families
and I've mentioned
we and
[Music]
with nothing kind of we developed the
fund method
and we used it to to show for that for
this class of problems that I didn't
Define all these two and problems or
expansion you can show that uh
before these extremal problems all the
solutions are essentially containing
fundas and also whenever the external
solution is a dictator we were able to
move it
this allowed us to make progress on
various open problems from the 70s
foreign
so we talked about extremal problems
we talked about the Elder Squad theorem
it says that the largest intersecting
family is a dictator
and we talked about the speed of Elder
Scroll taxilance so I want to show you
the external solution to an external
problem is indicated
we also talked about this winter method
that helps solve this elder scroll type
before I talk about it I
am
I wanted to mention a little bit more
about
the poof
and
[Music]
and then I want to explain the role of
hyperconductivity for Global functions
in these results
so basically what uh the new one fried
with method was
foreign
was to decompose
and intersecting f
aith
which they called uncapturable
let's define these what are these
uncapturable parts
so f is
R Epsilon capturable
it exists
our dictators
um
it's called them di1 up to Dil so these
are
the families of all sets that contain
and this is the family of our oceans to
contain i1
such that f is essentially contained in
their Union so
if we take F and count how many elements
is that outside of the Union
we get almost nothing
this is at most Epsilon times the size
of f
and uh
yeah I don't know how much control you
have over this but is there any way
the
I can't see the right
I can I can read it yeah I mean and
remove
um
okay we said it okay so
so and
okay so family is captured but if it's
almost contained the union of a small
amount of dictators
foreign
parts
[Music]
fine
in F1
bin F2
with
that's with the intersection of A and B
no names
and similar to the regularity method
additive combinatorics where the
composer
assets into pseudonym paths and then we
have this counting Lemma what we want
you want to analyze this pseudo random
palette to show
that they contain
configurations
so that was the idea and our additional
idea was instead of decomposing into
uncapsulated parts we decomposed into
Global paths
and the composers
um okay so it's basically similar to
what happened in Don't stock when you
have these restrictions
that each of these is uh uncapturable in
that case
in our case it's a global
I don't want to be too formal with it
but the main
their main idea was to decompose into
uncapsurable paths and we further
decomposed into Global paths and as I
mentioned this yesterday or two days ago
two days ago and at the mission two days
ago when you have a global family a
global function you can you can get back
the level linear quality
and and then you get exponentially
better
and that's what makes this decomposition
to Global paths together with the
hyperconductivity uh for Global
functions it makes the combination uh
very powerful so
basically
if you have a global part
gives you a level the inequality
then you get exponentially better
experience for the global parts
does it make it works
break
different slides
do we still need the slides yeah
I'll see the sideboards maybe I should
just right on the sideboard yeah it
depicts okay sure
okay anyways okay
yeah but anyways what's looking at here
is that we have these we decompose into
Global paths we get a better level
inequality and then
um because the nozzle paletto kills the
load the high degrees
and we can apply this level the
inequalities to get exponently better
tax serums
and now we're going to switch from
external Kombat X to other additive
communities
in groups
and
so in group Theory you have this problem
of okay so usually people care about sub
groups where the product of each two
elements in the subgroup is inside but
we will care about the opposite thing
where the quality of each tournaments in
the city is outside of the set
okay
but this problem actually is some
applications to growth in groups and
things
that even groups are always scared about
so
and bye
okay so okay so a set is products free
the productivity elements in a
is not an a
and the extremal problem corresponding
to this notion is how large can a
product is that to be
so
okay so I'm asking you to solve this the
case well this the group is the
symmetric group
[Music]
find the light for the screen
um okay
foreign
homomorphism
from SN to
plus minus one
and then if you take support notation
such that
sign is minus one the auto computation
then the product of which two
permutations with sine of minus one is
going to be of sine one
so this is a
Rolex preset
on the other hand if a
is a subset of the SN
sub service and the sports thing
okay
and G is in a
then a intersection with j
is empty
reflection is
so the intersection is empty that's this
means that a plus J
this is the most
go ahead so the size of a needs to be at
most and talk to a level two so this
means that this polish preset is the
largest products preset
that's for SN are there any questions
so now let's move on to this problem in
am
and this problem was posed by
and Baba and Josh in 1985
foreign
this problem in the alternating
and
Ben green is a list of 100 favorite open
problems and this was open number four
in that list and for us the appear was
that the conjunction of the external set
for this problem is somewhat of a
dictator so it looks like problems from
a message from Boolean functions might
be relevant for this program
yeah
okay so what are the dictators in the
alternating group so if you want to
check whether the permutation
belongs to the dictator we have to check
just one element this is like
one notion of a dictator
and because also basically
these guys so the
uh Define the set of computations they
send one to a set time
presets are the dictators
but that's not exactly true
because
and it's easy to show that you can come
up with two permutations then send one
to I but the product doesn't send one to
why there is no reason why the product
shoots in one point but after a small
modification
the indicators are what let's play
so we Define this
indicator a bottom mutation sending I
twice you can make it 43 by adding the
actual condition that the set I is sent
to its complement
and this set fii is actually support
so
if we have
for each Sigma of one is in I
and Tau of I is in the complement of I
then
and without Sigma of one is not deny so
if Sigma Tau belongs to the
to this family fii the small explicator
then the product doesn't belong to the
dictate
so the best I expect is wooden and then
the condition that one isn't why happens
probability one of the wooden and the
other condition that I simply to
complement this happens with the
constant probability so it's really
essentially addicted
IO it should be a roughly of size uh
okay and
gallons found this really nice post that
and
this was improved by Hebron to at the
minus one half up to login to the
seven so this is like
this old tilde is like log n
the seven halves
Victoria
and we managed to show the exact
external result so
foreign
this move is really about Randomness in
Telegraph
and
also about the Hoffman bound so if we
have
um
we have a graph
yes sir
it's Independence number
so let's let's say the maximum of an i
divided by G
or independent I
this is at most the minimal eigenvalue
of digestive symmetrics
divided by
one minus Lambda mean of digestive
symmetrics
that's the Offman bound
and that was
observation that if you have a politics
reset it's an independent set in the
telegraph that sa is a set of generators
so if
we have an edge A1 aa2
and
that with A1 and a
an A2 in a and also a is in a then we
get that a is not a product preset and
so that's why this set a needs to be
independent in the calligraph
and then you can apply the Hoffman bound
so if you get a good amount of
eigenvalues of G
you can get that
the independence sets need to be very
small
but but usually when you try to compute
the movement bound you have a given
graph at your disposal and then you can
do something to compute these
eigenvalues but here we have an
arbitrary Telegraph and that was needed
to come up with some ways to Autobahn
the second values
and what God also does not is not only
the minimal eigenvalue it's more in
absolute values but actually the
discussed and it's it has a it's a good
expander essentially
it's one idea was this movement bound
and the other area
[Music]
the other day is the transmission
so we have this notion and
we have two Notions the same to
contradict one ocean is symmetry
and the other notion is randomness
and they seem to contradict each other
but actually observation was that you
can use symmetry to deduce pseudor
randomness
uh very symmetric
and they have the the horse they have
the fullest n is the symmetric is the
sort of symmetries
and you can use the trace method to
deduce these choreographs must be pseudo
random
and the idea is quite simple so what he
did was
he looked at this
agency
Matrix of this operator or the
normalized one so we have this operator
T and TF of Sigma is the expectation
over a and a
of f a sigma
what you said
it's probably function okay so if you
have a function s in L2 of SM
okay
then we find this operator that
corresponds to and
this calligraph this averaging operator
corresponds to this calligraph
and then if we take a look at this style
and TF of Sigma
this is like taking the expectation of
um
hey
in a and a prime
in a inverse
and taking a f
of a prime a sigma
and then you can compute the trace of
pistol t
so what's that
this is the probability
normalization so we can
it's in Victoria
times the probability and that if you
take two steps of the random mark one
for a and one for its inverse you reach
to the same place
so this happens with probability one
over the size of a
so when you choose a prime it has to be
exactly a inverse in order for this in
order for to which the same element
and factorial divided by two times the
size of a
on the other hand this is the sum
of a
okay so let's assume for Simplicity that
the distal is equal to the
and then we'll get this is the sum of uh
over all the eigenvalues
with respect to move t
of the multiplicity of Lambda times
Lambda squared
so from this we get that if M Lambda if
the multiplicity is large
the Lambda
because we have this sum that's equal to
this number so the larger the
multiplicity this smaller the eigen
value is
and then you can use the representation
theory of SN to say that this m Lambda
it must be large for for
every function that's not the constant
function this m Lambda needs to be at
least n minus one and that's how GAO
also got is uh upper bound on polex
presets
and this result it uses the second
eigenvalue
it only uses the
the second smallest multiplicity of a
high dimensional representation
and but actually
for SN you have a
you have a similar decomposition into
the glue
like you have in the Boolean Cube
and the higher the degrees
the higher this m Lambda is
so
we know that loud gem Lambda implies
that Lambda is
we can decompose the space L2 of s and
as a direct sum
of these spaces would be equal to D will
be equal to this like in Max stock it's
the sum of all you take all the
functions of the grading the double
orthogonal functions of degree D minus
one and the function of degree is if
it's a linear combination of the juntas
to have this decomposition
into
the greedy functions and
inside the vehicle today
it must is larger it's like
it's roughly let's say n to the D
so and let's follow some of the
representation skill of the Symmetry
group the minimal person possible is n
minus one but inside of V equal to D the
this emblem does at least n to the D
and if you know representation Theory
this corresponds to this
books where you have D boxes below the
first one
yes
and
[Music]
yeah okay so that's the idea
operator
we get it the larger the degree is the
smaller the eigenvalue is
because the larger the multiplicity is
the larger that the smallest the
eigenvalue is so
to get this operator we defined that
earlier
and TS was the expectation
the a of fa Sigma
this operator it kills the high degree
and then when you combine it with
hyperconductivity and the level being
equality you can get a much better
results and that was our idea
and
that's why we
let's talk about
the methods
it's this
yes well let's talk about a lot
and
okay so here they'll
few applications maybe I should talk
about
um
both negations I don't know
[Music]
so a new application that though didn't
mention is that there
and
we have
observe these applications to external
problems and
recently we put one on the archive with
the odd pin and
we also put a paper on the archive for
external problems and
okay
using hyper productivity for Global
functions and to basically moved a sharp
evolution
hyper-conflictivity
where
globalness
implies that
you get basically for them
hypercube so provided to have optimal
globalness you get
that this thing here is at most
and expectation of x squared
divided by log one over the
transportation over
divided by D
iverted to the this power
and
so don't stop we talked about when
when we get this thing is it most
Epsilon times the two Norm of f
but we can't have the technology to get
everything that you have for the Boolean
Cube you can get basically for the
Symmetry group provided that you have
globalness
so that's with um
and and
yeah so so this
we did it for the product space
and then for SN
we find a new way to reduce it without
losing anything in the parameters so
this is with
um
Alice
symmetry book
we Define this coupling approach this is
and we use this coupling approach
already appeared in this work with uh
Yuval
and
and then
guys
we found this way to and
reduce type of quantitivity from to
reduce cycle conductivity on the
symmetric group which is a non-obedient
setting to the end to them which can be
sort of as an ability group as similar
than to then
but the original coupling approach has
some loss in the parameters and the
follow-up paper doesn't have roles in
the parameters and then we can get this
inequality
and
and then with a
behind mamo
we have
we took basically our levels inequality
and our hyperconductive inequality and
plugged in the characters of the
Symmetry group that are these are
important functions of
to them and we managed to give
and
the size estimates
to the Q Norms of data disabled
characters
these have a
lot of applications to conical
coefficients and
yeah
and
mixing times
on Ruby's classes
to an approximate the samples
well we want to show that if you have a
subset of the group such that 8 times 8
times a small then a is close to an
actual sample and
okay
if we have the noise operator this we
talked about
and
okay so I'm 10 minutes maybe maybe I'll
just give the
things we talked about
okay so let's talk about
um
so let's talk about this coupling
approaching SN
ack
[Music]
foreign
just about the coupling approach maybe
not in SN but in the P by settings this
is there and
Sleepless friends were
you can apply it so that's a method for
getting hyperconductivity for a space
for free without and without needing to
do
any calculations instead you have to
compute the eigen values of a certain
operator instead of computing the phone
number of an operator
you get hyperconductivity for free and
in order to do something about and in
order to reduce level difficulties you
have to compute this eigenvalues
and then
yeah okay and I'm going to will be to
deduce
to conductivity
[Music]
a new page from hyper complexity
so it turns out the theory you can
actually deduce hyperconductivity for
free without doing any work
so let's explain how that works
[Music]
what you can do you can Define you can
think of a bipartite graph
where in this side you have new Peak and
in the right hand side you have U1 hack
and
so all of them is the processes and the
Boolean Cube
and you
can define a coupling between them that
should correspond to some weighted graph
between them but if you want you can
think here of instead of new you can
think of and choose pm
and here
you can choose
and
but you can think of n divided by n over
2.
and now you'd like to define a random
model to correspond to starting with the
set here and taking an arbitrary subset
that contains it and you also have a
random Orkin other direction we'll start
with the circle and take another subset
of uh we take a random subset of it
foreign
so given
given a that's suppose we should think
of it as uniformly distributed we can
choose a random number of a
by
and
by letting
I not being B
whenever
I is not in a
so we're going to choose B that's going
and B is going to be containing a
so whenever I
is nothing a we also have I has to be
nothing B
then we have the case where I
is in a
and then we have to make B Be B biased
so
when I is in a we put in b
Mobility
and
and then we have to make sure that it's
going to be previous so the only way to
have to put it
[Music]
the only way that I could be in business
that if I is in a and then Mobility 2p
are going to bending so that makes BP by
X so that's a couplings between the
information and the device distribution
foreign
you can think of random walks that go
from one side to the other
coupling so we can Define so if you have
a function and F in L2 of mu P
you can define an operator T
from L2 suppose mu p
to L2
of me one half form
and you also have an operator pistol in
the reverse Direction it corresponds to
a random work in the reverse Direction
let's see
the potato T is given by letting TF of
um hey be the expectation
or will be
and I'm in the middle of it and I'm the
neighborhood according to the final mark
of Applebee
and this stock corresponds to a random
working derivative selection
and it turns out that if you take a
distal
and compose it with the noise operator
on the Boolean Cube
it was the and another product on the
Boolean Cube
okay so let's write it
let's write this SP
goes from
one half
and other one
so this is
a joint that goes in the reverse
Direction This is an operator from L2 of
mu P
white of mu p
foreign
to the uniform measure then in the
uniform measure you apply the noise
operator and then you go back to the
device measure
it turns out that if that
this thing is not a new operator this is
actually a noise operator with a
different parameter so that's one fact
if you take the composition of these
operators to get this operator of table
time
uh that just belongs to the northern it
corresponds to the
um
on the device too
that we defined earlier
and it turns out this operator is
hypocontractive for free so
so if people
as this type of contract with
probability that table two to Q is at
most one
inspect and
po F Q is that most F2
Paul F
and then we get this cable plan
and the same probability
so we'll find with some function of wall
and B so I didn't tell you like what's
its definition but it turns out that
when you compose these operators you get
different points of product
and you can calculate this Mobility by
following this a process
because and it's such a coincidence
because the another operator was the
unique operator that as this
Independence between the coordinates
and the here every every code and
everything happened independently so it
must be some noise
okay
I mean the proof is very simple
yes so I have
t
and
when we look at digital
T of s q Norm
we can realize that pistol is a
contraction every operator would
correspond to a random mock is a
constant it's a contraction so we can
get rid of this this stuff then we can
talk about it using hyperconductivity
and then we can get rid of this thing
because it is also combustion so
basically you get hyperconductivity for
free
and the
and that's how you can pull deduce the
hypomonductivity in the p-bus cube from
hyperconductivity in the uniform Cube
and turns out this method is really
General and you can apply it in the
Symmetry group to reduce stuff from the
wallet space setting and you can apply
it for matrices to reduce things from
the corresponding billionaire Group
which is called the millennial skin and
and probably I should
soon stop but I just wanted to put
okay so I wanted to put two messages out
of the talk so first of all that
and
that in a and we get this the next
preset is a dictator so this external
problems appear also in additive
communities and group ceiling and the
other message of the talk is that you
have this disciple conductivity for
Global functions is a
basically everywhere so that's what
uh
so any questions to know
[Music]
you'll get some noise operator was going
to get
yeah and then you can get uh you you can
deduce Global hyper conductivity from
the slides to the pbase cube and then it
will be more involved you'll have to
show that this coupling operator
preserves to globalness which it does in
the case of SN so snu
use this coupling to get it into and to
them and you see you show that the
global axis preserved and then you get
any more questions
so so I should think of the
SE yeah
what happened this coupling you can
think of as a weighted by parted graph
because it gives you like a distribution
so you can think of it as a random Edge
in the glass
goes from one side to the other and back
and this random walk you have operator C
and T cell
to correspond to it and these operators
automatically contractions because it's
true for every random work on a bypass
attack and then when you decompose when
you take the composition of these
operators you get automatically a
hyperconductive operator and here you
just have to realize that it's the noise
operator in general you get if you want
to reduce hyperconductivity for the
Symmetry group you'll get some weird
operator on SN and you have to compute
its eigenvalues to deduce something
meaningful so it's not automatic you'd
have you really have to do some do some
representation theory in order to
compute diagonal values of the operator
that you get when you apply this process
so
okay so let's check Norm again
[Applause]
so we'll return after lunch at 2PM